flood waters that forced yellowstone
national park to close are now causing
heavy damage in nearby montana the
state's biggest city is at risk of
running out of drinking water after the
flooding affected its water treatment
plant a statewide emergency has been
declared as jonathan vigliotti reports
officials say the park may never look
the same after its worst flooding in
decades
these are the flood waters that tore
through red lodge montana which some say
came without warning
roads turned into rivers in a matter of
minutes i woke up to my
10 year old screaming downstairs the
water was flowing so quickly and rising
so fast that i needed to get the
breakers off
they are the same waters that devastated
yellowstone national park earlier this
week
leaving scars on one of the nation's
oldest most treasured landmarks one
aspect of climate change is that we're
going to see more extreme weather events
and i think we're seeing that
not only in montana but around the
country and around the world
events that really exceed what we've
seen in recorded history
the montana national guard has flown
some 90 people to safety when was the
last time you saw something like this no
one's ever seen anything like this red
lodge fire chief tom kuntz says some 250
homes have been damaged by the floods
that boulder right there gives you a
sense of the power of this water that
that boulder originally was in our main
street the river literally came right
through here and went through these
folks house the river was going through
their living room
says the weather here has been both
extreme and unpredictable a year ago we
were on fire a year later were wet we
have the highest stream flows that the
area has ever seen experts fear even the
nation's most protected national parks
like yellowstone are now at risk because
of our changing climate we have to
really plan for change the
infrastructure in places like
yellowstone is not ready for climate
change
we're seeing roads wash out landslides
we need to give that some more thought
and the water has receded here in red
lodge leaving behind what you could not
see in the water at the time these are
massive boulders some of them easily
hundreds of pounds that came from the
riverbed putting into perspective just
how strong that current was the fire
chief telling me in his 27 years he has
not seen a single flooding event in fact
just last week he was talking with one
of his colleagues they have thousands of
sandbags they were actually thinking of
giving them away
tony wow
so much power in that water and if it's
not the flooding as far as you've
pointed out it's it's the fires they're
getting it from both sides jonathan
bigliotti thank you very much